اوكي
مجلس
الانتخابي رئيسا للمجلس في جلسات جديده
ومكان فيه يعزز فرصا فوزه
[تصفيق]
ضربات متبادله واشنطن تحذر من استخدام
روسيا للهدن لتنظيم وتجميع قوتها
وفاته متظاهرا ايراني جراء جروح اصيب بها
بدايه الانتفاضه في زاهدان جنوب الشرقيه
ايران
[موسيقى]
اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره
الاخباريه من العربيه
خطا المرشحوا لرئاسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
خطوه مهمه نحو ضمان فوزه بالمنصب بعد شلل
استمر ثلاثه
الانباء بان كارتي تمكن من اقناعه غالبيه
الجمهوريين في التيار المحافظ والبالغ
عددهم عشرون نائبا بدعم
وهذه الصور مباشره من الولايات المتحده
للجوله اول اليوم الثالث من التصويت
النواب على اختيار رئيسهم خلفا لنانسي
بيلوسي 14 جوله كانت لم تحسم فيها
مراسل العربيه حسين الطود حسين ما هي
الصوره الان لديك
[موسيقى]
من الماضي
لكنه حتى الان يبدو انه لم ينجح بالفوز اا
في رئاسه مجلس النواب الان مشاهد ما يجري
هناك حديث بين مكارثه همم الذي همم
التصويت حتى النهايه
كان بحاجه همم ربما لصوت اخر لكي يفوز
بهذه الجلسه يفوز برئاسه انه طبعا الان
هناك عمليه حسابيه معقده بان يمتنع
المعارضون على التصويت لكي تقل عتبه همم
الاصوات المطلوبه
2018 الى 217 او 216 كان بحجر لصوت له احد
همم هؤلاء
ولكن هو بدل من يصوت او او يلتزم همم
يلتزم الصمت او يصوت بحاضر لكن صوت
لشخص اخر همم عقد العمليه كان هناك
مفاوضات حتى اللحظات الاخيره حتى خلال
التصويت نشاهد الان كيف هناك جدل بين
مكارتي همم
بين الجمهوريين همم
لا نعرف ماذا يقولون بالضبط في الحقيقه
ولكن لا يبدو ان مكارته سعيد همم اما نفسه
قبل هذه الجلسه بعد رفع الجلسه السابقه
بانه لديه الاصوات الكافيه ليفوز في
الجوله الرابعه عشر من التصويت ولكن هذا
لم يحدث حتى الان على ما يبدوا كما قلت
عادل يتعاقد العمليه عندما صوت اسنان
بحاضر بينما صوت اربعه اخرون همم ضد همم
كارتي لمرشحين اخرين ما همم لم يسمح له
بالفوز حسب ما نشاهد الان همم
ستكون لك ايضا مفاوضات اخرى انه نذكر
بانكر قدم الكثير من التنازلات خلال هذا
اليوم والايام السابقه ولكن هذه التنازلات
يبدو انها لم تقنع همم
ما بقيتش حتى الان الذي اصرف الحقيقه منذ
البدايه بدايه التصويت همم وقبل ذلك بانه
لم يصوط لصالح مكه
بحاضر يعني وما زال عند كلمته همم نشاهد
خيبه الامل على وجوه الجمهوريين همم الان
همم رغم الجلوس همم قرب لوران التي ايضا
صوتت بحاضر همم هذه التصويت
حاضر يعتبر انجازا ااه قبل قليل لانها لم
تصوت منافس لمكارسي في الحقيقه حتى
التصويت بحاضر كان يعتبر لصالح مكارتي
لانه كان
سيخفض العتبه عتبه
الارقام المطلوبه للفوز لكن يبدو ان
مكارتي الان ما زال كان بحاجه الى صوت اخر
لكي يكون 217 صوت لكي يفوز لانه سوف
[موسيقى]
نوعا ما معقده بالتصويت بضد همم مكارثي او
حتى الامتناع عن التصويت لكن ماذا سنفعل
حينما تتجه الامور الى عدم حسم هذه الجوله
حسين
سيكون هناك جوله اخرى من المؤكفه يكون
هناك جوله اخرى اذا لم تحزن هذه الجوله
طبعا لا يوجد عدد واحد او عدد محدد ليقف
عنده كما ذكرنا في نشرات سابقه عام 1856
كان هناك
استمرت التصويت لمده شهرين اكثر من 110
جولات من الانتخابات حتى حزم الامر
الموضوع يعني يطول لان نحن في الجوله
الرابعه عشر وقد فشلوا بها فشل مكارثي
بالفوز قبل قليل كان هناك حالات من
التفاؤل
كناسيه عندما صوت همم
حاضر همم تفاءل الكثيرون من الجمهوريين
وحتى المحللين الاعلاميين قالوا انهم كان
في اقترب كثيرا ولا في انه كان صرحها قبل
التصويت بانه لديها الاصوات الكافيه اللي
يفوز بهذه الجوله برئاسه مجلس النواب ولكن
ما جرى بالتفاصيل ان ما بقيت عندما انوفي
على اسمه في المره الاولى لم يصوط همم خرج
من الجلسه وحتى قيل بانه لم يكن في في
القاعه ثم دخلوا وجلس
قربت النائبه جمهوريه ايضا كان هناك تفاعل
الجميع يتحدث على ان همم هذا الشيء همم
علامه ايجابيه همم
خاصه بعد ما صوت
لصالح مكه في همم كان هناك تفاعل بانه بان
المنقار فيه النجاح
باقناع همم
الجمهوريين السته الاخرين الذي الذين
كانوا يقفون ضده هو كانوا على موقفهم بانه
نجح باختراقهم في الحقيقه هو نجح ب- ب-
بتعديل موقفهم يعني
تعديل موقف منهم من ان يصوتوا بحاضر ولكن
الاربعون همم لم يغيروا موقفهم والان
العمليه ولا هي عمليه تعتمد على على
حسابات معقده ولكن مما نراه الان من خيبه
الامل على وجوه الجمهوريين ومن رده فعل
مكار سيدي بانه لم يستطع ان ان يفوز
بالرئاسه مجلس النواب حتى في هذا التصويت
همم ننتظر طبعا ماذا سيحدث تفسيرات اخرى
بحسب الكثير من المحللين كانوا يقولون بان
هذه النتيجه ان لا يصور همم ضده ان يصوتوا
حتى لو صوت اربعه الاخرون فينجحوا سينجح
مقارتي ولكن حتى الان يبدو ان ان الامر
همم لم ينجح به همم
نقول ربما في في اللحظات الاخيره قد يكون
هناك تغير للمواقف امام اننا نتجه الى همم
ممكن ان يغير النائب الذي يصور همم تصويته
في اخر اللحظات همم
لربما هذا ما ما يتم الحديث عنه هذا ما
يتم همم الحوار
همم
نرى هناك جمهوريون نواب جمهوريون يتحدثون
معه نربما يغير همم تصويطه الامر كما قلنا
هو متعلق به الان هو من لديه القدره على
حسن همم نتيجه
مكارثي اذا كان او سيفوز ام لا الامر بيده
وحده الان همم لهذا نرى همم هذا الحوار
معهم من قبل الجمهوريين هناك مشاورات
كثيره نعم يعني هل هناك حديث عن ماذا يريد
هؤلاء الذين يرفضون التصويت الى مكان فيه
رغم انهم اعضاء في الحزب همم الجمهوري هل
هناك مجال للمساوامات ماذا يريدون من مكان
يعني يعدل او حتى ان يكون مستقبلا ان يقف
مع بعض المشاريع او القوانين
هم لديهم مطالب كثيره بدءا من موضوع تسهيل
التصويت على عزل رئيس مجلس النواب الذي
اعطاها لهم بكار في كانو كان الامر يتطلب
خمسه اعضاء جمهوريين الان يتطلب عدو واحد
ليصوته على ازاله الرئيس رئيس مجلس النواب
هم يطالبون بزياده اعداد
[موسيقى]
همم الجمهوريين من طيارهم الذي يوصف
بالمتشدد في اللجان الاساسيه وفي اللجان
الفرعيه يسيطر اكثر على العمليه التشريعيه
خاصه فيما فيما يتعلق
بالمشاريع همم التي تعنى بالميزانيه هم
يريدون ان ان تكون لهم همم يعني يدعو عليا
عليها لانهم يعتبرون ان الديمقراطيون
بالغه
الحكومي وفي ظل همم
التضخم وانا انا انفاقهم همم فهم كثيرا به
التضخم يطالبون اي يعني يكون لهم همم
القدره على مراجعه القوانين قبل ثلاثه
ايام من ارسالها لمجلس النواب لديهم
العديد من المطالب لكن ابرز هذه المطالب
كما قلت همم عادل هي ايضا تتعلق تتمور
بزياده اعداد همم تيارهم في اللجان
الاساسيه ل- ل- حتى مو كما يقول بعض
المحللين اكثر في المجلس وحتى بمكار في
ولهذا كان هناك تحضيرات من قبل همم
الجمهوريين الذين يوثقون بالمعتدلين من
تقديم المزيد من التنازلات لهم لان ذلك
هذه التنازلات ضعف همم
مركز همم او منصب رئاسه مجلس النواب
وتجعلها
رهينه بيدهم وهذا ايضا يحذر منه
الديمقراطيون همم النقاش الان همم بين همم
في الولايات المتحده همم في همم الوسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه حول همم ان هذه
المجموعه الصغيره من الجمهوريين هما
السكان و20 همم نائبا الان ياخذون كل شيء
رهينه ياخذون الحكومه رهينه كما يقال في
العلامه الامريكي همم يشكلون حتى المملكه
من يعتبر من المشكلون خطرا لان الان مجلس
النواب في حاله همم شلل
يعني وهذا هذا ايضا هذه الشكاوى تصدر من
الجمهوريين الذين اشتكوا خاصه من الذين
سيكونون رؤساء لللجان الاساسيه تحديدا مثل
لجنه الاستخبارات والاجنبيه همم القوات
المسلحه والنجمه الخارجيه يشتكون بانهم لا
يستطيعون الان همم الوفي
بوعودهم التي قطعوها مثل المراقبه اداره
الرئيس بعدا عن كسب اجراء تحقيقات مثل
تحقيق حول الانسحاب الذي يصفونه بالفوضووي
من افغانستان ايضا بالنسبه لتحقيقات بشان
عائله
خاصه ابنه ايه هانتر بايدن كل هذه الامور
متوقفه لان اللجان الان لا تعمل لان
النواب لم يؤدوا القسم حتى الان بسبب عدم
انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب الامور هناك هناك
شلل شبه شلل في مجلس النواب لا يمكن ادخال
اي مشروع الى المجلس يمكن اقرار اي مشروع
اي تشريع طالما ان رئيس المجلس لمنتخب بعد
كل هذه الامور تشكل يعني كره ثلج تكبر
وتدبر ولهذا السبب هناك ضغوط الان تمارس
على هؤلاء وحتى على ماكر
يتنحر ربما او يترك المجال لغيره ولكن
الرجل همم يعني كما اثبت وكما يقول عنه
الاعلام الامريكي رجل العنيد ويعاندهم
صحيح يقدم تنازلات ولكنه لم يتنحى او لن
يتنازل عن هدفه للوصول الى رئاسه مجلس
النوافيرها انها انه يستحق بها بسبب همم
عمله طويل يجلس النواب انه ل الان وكما
حتى الان لديه 216 صوتا هو لديه الاغلبيه
في هذا المجلس من الجمهوريين طبعا نتحدث
لهذا هو يرى نفسه انه الحق برئاسه المسجد
وحتى البديل المطروح الذي طرح اسمه سيف
سكاليز همم هو من نفس المدرسه ولذلك يقول
العديد من الجمهوريين المعتدلين بانه لا
فرق بين اشكال
وانها هؤلاء المتشددين همم 20 نائبا
سيصوتونا ضد اشكال همم مثل ما صوت ضد مكه
هذا في الحقيقه يعني جدد كبير الان داخل
الحزب الجمهوري وكما قلنا بانه قله عددهم
الان الان
نتحدث عن مكان في حصل على 216 صوت
نعم
الان نرى هذا التصفيق
لمكارسي لكن حتى الان لم يحسم الامر حسين
[موسيقى]
العتبه وقد نجح
اذا
اعتقد ذلك
من
الجمهوريين صوتها
بحاضر ولم يصلي
لمرشح اخر
فالعتبه المطلوبه للفوز برئاسه مجلس
النواب انخفضت ولكن
يبدو بانها لم تنخفض يعني بهذه التعقيدات
الحسابيه ايضا ربما لم تسمح لمقارته
لم تسمح لم ينجح مكان سياسي
تكون هي الجوله القادمه
لانه لانه هناك يعني كما قلت كان قبل
بدايه هذا التصويت كان هناك
حديث هناك تحليلات تقول بان اثنين اذا اذا
امتنع عن التصويت او صوت طاب حاضر ستنخفض
العتبه
اثنان تنعال الان
ولكنهم اه نعم نعم لم ينجح لم ينجح مكارسي
دات لديه الرقم الذي يؤهله لانه يكون
رئيسا وبالتالي قد ايه نتجه الان الى جوله
ثانيه همم جوله جديده اللي عاده تصوير
الجوله الخامسه عشره اذن همم قد تكون همم
حسم هذا المنصب قد يستطيع تغيير بعض همم
النواب الذين صوتوا
ضده او حتى
يتجهون الى الامتناع
الذين صوتوا بحاضر لو صوت لصالحه لكن فاز
بهذه همم الانتخابات لكنهم همم لم لكان
حصل علامات 217 صوتا
وبذلك تنخفض العتبه همم عتبه الاصوات
المطلوبه الى 217 بدل 200 218 ولكن بما
انه اثنين من النواب صوتوا بحاضر لم لم
تنجح هذه همم العمليه الحسابيه المعقده
كما قلت لك يعني تحليلات كلها اليوم كانت
تتحدث عن هذه العمليه بانه حاول اقناع
العديد منهم بان همم الان الان التصويت
الذي نراه امامنا هو التصويت همم تاجيل
الجلسه همم هذه العمليه كما قلت همم عادل
همم لم ينجح بها ايضا كان في رغم انه كان
متفائلا قبل التصويت تحدث
[موسيقى]
المعارضين لانه
متاكد من انه سيفوز بهذه همم الجلسه ولكن
بالفعل يعني همم ما ت- جيت الذي احتفظ
بالصوته حتى النهايات تسبب بهزيمته كان
الامر بيده وسوط بحاضر ما قلب الموازين
وقلب حتى الحسابات
المعقده
والنتيجه الان سنذهب الى التصويت همم
بالجوله الخامسه عشر تحدد اذا كان سينجح
ام لا همم طبعا عندما ينتهي التصويت عادل
همم وحتى خلال التصويت تكون هناك مفاوضات
الان خلال التصويت هذا الذي رايناه كان
هناك مفاوضات عندما همم رفض في البدايه
يعني بصوته همم كان هناك مفاوضات معه من
قبل همم انصار في ولكنه همم بقي عنده رايه
او ربما نستطيع ان نقول انه يغير قليلا
بانه صوت بحاضر لكن كان مك- يحتاج الى
التصويت لصالحه همم له هو وليس بحاضر همم
لكن ما جرى همم يعني عكس ما كان يعمل به
همم
الى يوم غد ربما هذه الجوله همم حتى يوم
الاثنين اذا معناته يعني سيكون نهايه
الاسبوع في الولايات المتحده وبعد ذلك الى
يوم الاثنين حيث عادت الجول او ربما ندخل
الى الجوله الخامسه عشر
نعم
للتصويت على انتخاب الرئيس اذا سوف نعطيك
المجال للقراءه لافضل همم بالصوره همم قد
تكون معنا في نشرتنا اللاحقه حسين شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات وكل هذا
الشرح
والتفصيل حولنا همم نكون خطوه بخطوه مع
هذا التصويت في مراحله الاخيره شكرا جزيلا
حسين مراسل العربيه من واشنطن
نعود الى الملف الاوكراني حتى هو الروسي
حيث يتبادلت كل من موسكو وكيف اتهامات
بشان حدوث ضربات من الجانبين خلال اليوم
الاول من هدنه من طرف واحد اعلن عنها
الرئيس الروسي بلادي مير بوتين من جانب
واحد وقالت مصادر العسكريه في بخمس ان ان
الهدنه مجرده استفزاز روسي يساعد المدنيين
في المدينه التي تعرضت لقصف متواصل مع ذلك
رئيس اداره الرئاسه الاخرانيه
القوات الروسيه
عسكريتين كما استهدفت ايضا مدينه خيرسون
من جهه اكد الجيش الروسي احترامه الهدنه
المتهم القوات الاوكرانيه بمواصله قصف
المدن والمواقع الروسيه
الرئيس الاوكرانيه بلاد ميرزالسكي رحب
بالتزام الولايات المتحده بتزويد كيف
بعربات برادلي المقاتله لاول مره وقال ان
هذا هو بالضبط ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا لمواجهه
روسيا
هذا هو بالضبط ما نحتاجه مدافع وقذائف
جديده بما في ذلك الصواريخ الموجهه بدقه
صواريخ جديده وطائرات بدون طيار جديده
اسلوب قوي وفي الوقت المناسب
افاد موقع حال ويش ان محمد رجعي احد جرحى
الجمعه الداميه في زهدان جنوب شرقيه ايران
توفي بعد سبعه سنوات يوما بسبب شده
الاصابات وكان ريغي قد اصيب برصاص القوات
الامنيه الايرانيه في البطن والكلى والرئه
والكبد
هذه النشره مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل
واشنطن تسمح باستخدام العقاري اللي كان ما
بقلي معالجه الاشخاص الذين يعانون من
المراحل المبكره للازهايمر
حياكم الله اهلا بكم من جديد
بعد عامين على الهجوم ضد مبنى الكابيتول
لشدد الرئيس الامريكي جوبادل على ان لا
مكان للعنف سياسي في الولايات المتحده وان
امريكا بلاد قانون وليست بلاد فوضى
تصريحات بيض جاءت خلال تكريمه عناصر في
الشرطه مواجهت في ذلك اليوم حشدا غاضبا من
انصار الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب او بسبب
شهاداتهم امام لجنه التحقيق البرلمانيه في
تلك الاحداث
اتهم الرئيس التونسيه قيس سعيده اطرافن لم
يسميها بارتكابها افعال لا ترتقي الى
مرتبه التامر على امن الدوله الداخليه
والخارجي معتبرا انها جريمه لا علاقه لها
لا بحريه الفكر ولا حريه التعبير كما دعا
الرئيس التونسي الى تطبيق القانون على كل
من يتجاوزه
قالت الشركه الادويه اليابانيه ايسائي
انها سعره تعقرها الذي تمت المصادقه عليه
مؤخرا لعلاج مرض الزهايمر عند 26 الف وخمس
مئه دولار في السنه وسمحت اداره الاغذيه
والعقاقير الامريكيه باستخدام العقاري
المعروف كيميائيا باسم اللي كان عبر وضعه
على مسار الموافقه السريع للاشخاص الذين
يعانون من المراحل المبكره من المرض
في نهايه النشره هذا تذكره باب برزاوي
مجلس النواب الامريكيه يفشلوا للمره
الرابعه عشر في انتخابيه رئيس للمجلس سواء
جلسه جديده مقرره يوم الاثنين
بضربات متبادله واشنطن تحذر من استخدام
روسيا للهدنه لتنظيم والتجميع قوتها
وفاه متظاهرين اصيب بها شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]